a grand jury in the U.S state of Georgia
has issued 10 indictments in its
investigation into Donald Trump's
attempts to overturn the 2020
presidential elections those charge in
the case in Georgia have not yet been
named the former president has been
criminally indicted three times so far
this year Well Al jazeera's John hendren
joins us live now from Atlanta John so
the Georgia grand jury has issued these
10 indictments what more can you tell us
about the charges John
well for the fourth time Donald Trump
has been convicted of crimes against the
country that he was governing these
charges include racketeering one of
several charges against Donald Trump and
that is listed as a serious felony all
the rest are listed as felony what that
means is that this is a charge that
carries a sentence of up to 20 years in
prison and here in Georgia there's a
minimum sentence of five years in prison
so it's a very serious charge for a man
who's trying to be elected president one
time again there were also as many as 18
other people who have faced indictment
on this same list of documents and they
include the former white house chief of
staff Mark Meadows they include Rudolph
Giuliani the president's former personal
attorney who had been leading the
campaign to suggest that Trump had won
that election Something That Never Was
proven and that is the basis for these
charges also John Eastman another
attorney attorney Ken cheeseborough and
Jeffrey Clark who was a senior justice
department official who according to the
indictment was willing to make a
statement had actually drawn up a
document suggesting that there were
serious concerns by the justice
department that document was never
issued because there were a lot of other
people in the Trump campaign who were
not comfortable with it but what this
means is that the president the former
president phases a fourth very serious
indictment and unlike the two federal
indictments he faces one in Washington
D.C for his efforts to overturn the
election and his efforts around the
January 6 2021 Insurrection he faces a
charge charges of mishandling documents
in Florida those are federal charges as
well and he faces charges in New York
state for a scheme to pay off a former
porn star he allegedly had an affair
with to quiet her ahead of the election
this one would be another very serious
series of charges against the former
president and in those State charges
unlike the federal charges if he becomes
the president he doesn't have the pardon
rights over those State charges so these
would be very very difficult for him to
get rid of so some very serious charges
facing the former president of the
United States among the most serious in
those four series of indictments and
there are a number of people in that
Trump orbit who are also listed under
those indictments and that means this is
really the most wide-reaching case so
far in terms of the number of people
named John as you say it would be the
fourth set of indictments against the
former president how is all of this
likely to affect his Run for the White
House next year then
well the crazy thing is that though more
often he's indicted the more money he
raises and believe it or not the higher
his poll numbers go among Republican
voters it seems counter-intuitive but
those voters according to polls
seem to feel that attack on him is an
attack on his voting base as well but in
a more technical sense there is nothing
in the Constitution that says you cannot
run for president if you've been
convicted of a crime there's an
exception for treason but that's not
exactly what these charges are one could
make the argument that he should not be
able to run again because of that but
that would be something that would have
to be tested in court and of course
nothing like that has ever happened
before so now Trump can continue going
forward with his campaign his campaign
is already issued a statement saying
these charges could have been leveled
more than two years ago he says they're
just an attempt to derail his efforts to
win the presidency again all right John
hendron live us there in Atlanta John
thank you